thank you very much
thank you thank you very much for all
the pi data team for having me
hey okay let me share my screen here and
thank you thank you very much everyone
for
for assisting to the talk it's great to
see this this
amazing community so let me share here
i think you should be able to see me now
can you see me yeah works great awesome
perfect
okay so we're going to talk about let me
minimize this
yeah we're going to talk about serving
machine learning easily with fast api so
fast api is a high performance
easy to learn and fast to code and ready
for production
framework this is what we're going to
talk about
so first a little bit who am i i'm
sebastian ramirez
i'm a developer at explosion in berlin
germany i'm actually originally from
colombia
that's why the accent you can find me on
github linkedin twitter
everything i work for explosion
explosion are the creators of spacey
which is a
natural language processing uh toolkit
that you probably know of
for doing like a machine learning
processing over text
prodigy which is the annotation tool
with active learning so that you can
annotate
your data sets while retraining the
model
uh live while you add annotations and
think
which is the a deep learning framework
using type intentions
and a functional programming ideas i
personally created fast api
and typer we are going to talk about
fast api so
what's about fast api fast api is this
framework that now has like 15 000 gig
of stars it's been growing for about
1 000 star stars per month in github so
people seem to have been liking it
it's currently used by microsoft uber
netflix and a bunch of other people
for products and for their internal
systems and the performance is in the
top rank
for python but why would it be useful
for machine learning people like
what what is the deal about it that will
make
what makes it make sense for machine
learning
so that's what we are going to see so
i will assume i assume you know machine
learning you know the basics of web api
development like just the
the basics i mean just http
json you know what's an http request
just that
and nothing else so fast api
er is based and let's talk about like a
little bit of
what is fast api and what does it give
you fast api is based on standards open
api
json schema or two these
standards and these things a allow like
a much better integration with many
other tools
uh because of that facility i can
provide you automatic api documentation
like this thing that you
see here on the side this is generated
automatically from your code you don't
have to do anything
special to have it just because it's
based on
standards so you write very simple code
and uk
you get an api based on standards just
for free you don't have to do
anything to anything special to get that
a fast api is based on python type hints
or type annotations this is part of the
python
standard it's not like a new syntax or
anything we're going to see
a a an example like this a little bit
later but the thing is that
these type annotations are what powers a
autocompletion in your editor and type
checks and type errors
in your editor completion are things
like this
when you get a auto completion for
attributes or of objects
and type checks are what tells you that
some data that you are using in your
code is incorrect and it won't work
so the types are the thing that provides
auto completion and fast api is based on
these types and is based on
the ideas of having auto completion for
everything so we
get auto completion everywhere in our
code
when we write code with fast api
er so fastbase easy unsure it's very
simple
this code here this is a completely
valid fast api application
so we just have to from fast api import
the fast api class
then we create an application object of
type
fast api and then we use this this
add symbol here this is a decorator in
case you're not familiar with
the with this this is this thing is just
modifying
the function that is below in fast api
it actually doesn't modify it it just
like
registers it and what this is doing is
it's saying whenever someone goes to the
url slash
or like the root url of this application
and sends an http get request
we want this function to handle that
request
and what this function is doing is just
returning a dictionary with some message
we don't have to uh return some special
type
of or class or something we just can
just return a dictionary
directly and fast api will take care of
converting that to json
so we can read json on the other side
and by writing this simple code hey
okay well we are writing very little
code
because it's like quite short so the
more fast api code you write
the less api code you end up writing
like most of the code that you write
ends up being the business logic of your
application and the
the code that you need to do to process
your data to run your model
to uh all the logic that you need to to
add for is for for your specific
application because
a fast api tries to get out of the way
and let you just like
write your code uh that like the main
part
of your application now let's say that
you have
a machine learning model in this case
this will be a spacey
model so we are doing natural language
processing here we are going to do
entity extraction so we create an object
which is this spacey model and then we
pass
some text to this spacey model and we
were going to extract
the entities for each one of the
entities recognized
in this document so for each one one of
these entities we're going just to print
what is the text and what is the label
so this model recognize that we have
apple
which is an organization uk which is a
geopolitical entity or like a location
uh one billion that is money so this is
just a simple model
this could also be like a tensorflow
model a pi torch model
any type of machinery model that you
need to use and this is just like a
very simple machine learning processing
pipeline
to generate some type of a value on the
other side
so you have a machine learning uh enamel
model you have a chain learning model
now what
what are we going to do with that so
let's make it a web api
why would you make it a web api maybe to
show it to your colleagues to integrate
it with other internal apps or maybe
even to deploy to production or to like
build the product
right away so a web api in many cases is
like the
way that you can communicate from
the external world or from other systems
or services
or even users directly with your model
and with your
own code but first
let's take a look at what a basic fast
api
app would look like and what are like
the main parts so we are doing here this
is the same that we have before from
fast api import a fast api we create the
object
we add the same thing that we have
before notice that this time we are not
using an async
function this is a normal function fast
api
underneath is an asynchronous framework
uh but if you use a sync a normal
definition a normal a function
definition
it will do the right thing to make it
run
in a thread pool or yeah well like the
technical details
the thing is that it will work it will
work and it will do a
what it has to do so that you can just
like use normal functions and it will
just work
correctly if you know about a sink and
weight
and these things then you can like use
them
and like get all the benefits from them
that
if you don't you can just simply use
normal functions and it will just work
now let's create another another
endpoint
so we are saying that this is the the
path that we are going to take is going
to be slash
items and then in curly braces with path
with us a variable here
these curly braces are the same that we
use in
f strings so like the formatted strings
in
in python we are just not putting the f
here
because a because we don't have a
variable item id but the syntax is the
same so you can
it's easy to remember and then this item
id
is going to be a variable that goes in
the path and then we are receiving that
same variable
here in the function and we are
declaring this is a type
annotation or a type a hint this is a
standard python
we're just saying that this item id this
is an integer and then we can like treat
this integer inside of the function
so we're saying that this item id will
be of type integer and we are going we
are
also adding this extra parameter q which
is of time
string which is by default none because
it is by default
none then it won't be required and
because it's not of this
path here fast api will automatically
know that it will take it
from the query parameters so this is the
the how the application would look like
let's say that we have the application
deployed to somedomain.com
we have the slash items is these same
slash items here
and the item id here is the same a item
id
here this is the variable that we are
passing which is an integer
and then this q will be a query
parameter so the value of this queue
will be this sum query that we are
sending here then we are just like
returning it just like for the demo
uh but this is the url this is how this
would look like and how
we will interact with it but then
with this code when you check the
documentation
when you check this url the slash docs
fast api will automatically generate
this documentation user interface based
on your code you don't have to do
anything for
it to work we get the slash
main endpoint that we declared before
and we get the other one that we just
declared that we have items we have the
item id
which is a path parameter we also see it
here
is this item id which is required and
it's an integer it must be an integer
it goes in the path and we get the query
that goes
that goes here which is the same if we
go back is
the same query that goes here so
just by declaring very simple
for you so you just declared a standard
function and fast api
does this documentation for you so you
write basic code and fast api makes
address ui for you
now let's say that we want to create a
basic fast api application that receives
a body because we'll probably receive
some data
for our machine learning model so now
we're going to say that we want to
receive
some data that contains an article and
this article is going to be a json
a object a and json object is a temp
for like let's say in python that
dictionary
and it will contain a key content and a
key comments
uh this is like a
a normal class definition this is a
this uh this way of declaring these
variables
is the same that you will use with data
classes which is a part of
the latest versions of python
and these comes this base model comes
from pydentic
fast api is tightly integrated with
identical and uses
it uses it underneath to generate like
all the data validation
and the documentation and all these
things
so we are creating this class that is
going to have a content
which is a string and we have a comments
which is
a list of strings and by default is an
empty list
then we can declare a variable here this
is now
the same thing that we have been doing
we use the decorator with app and then
we do
the post this means that the http
request is going to be
a post a method post request
and this goes to slash article slash and
we are receiving this
article variable which is of type
article and this
article here is the same class that we
created here
above so we are taking this article
which is this this
json shape and we are going to receive
it as json and then because
the thing that we receive inside is
actually an instance so we are saying
that article is of type
a the class article this means a in
normal python we are saying this is an
instance of this class
and because we are actually receiving an
instance of that class we can use this
article dot content we can use dot
notation to extract the values we don't
have to
use a keys in a dictionary and have to
remember what were the names of the keys
that we declared before we can just like
use
a dot notation here this is just
uh an f string a formatted string so we
are integrating this content inside of
the yes
now we return we just return this
message and when we
check the documentation user interface
we can see that the example value
contains the same shape that we declared
so this is the json
shape or the json schema that we will
send to the api it has a content which
is a string and then it has a comments
which is a list
of strings if we come back we have the
content which is a string and the
comments which is a list of strings
so the documentation is also updated
automatically with the data that we
declared
now if we hit let's go back if we hit
this try
it out button in the documentation
interface in the browser
we get the chance to interact with our
api live
directly and we can just send some data
like this here we send this content and
it has some string and we send the
comments
it has some strings inside of this list
we send that to our api that is like
running there with our code and we get
the the results
that we are that we are just sending
back this is the message and we are
sending
the content back which is the thing that
we are returning in record if we go back
to the code
we are turning message and this is the
the the article content that we are
turning
so we can interact with your data live
with this interactive
user interface for the documentation of
our api
so we just have code we already made an
api with a request body that
is automatically documented and like
just works and it's ready to be used
now let's say that we want to build a
fast api application that takes a body
and a query parameter we can just do the
same that we were doing before we
declare one parameter of type article
and now we're going to clear this other
a parameter
big model of type boolean that by
default is
false because this is a simple data
shape this is not uh
like a complex data shape like this one
this doesn't like contain
sub values is just a boolean the first
api
will know that it has to take it from
the query parameter and by default
is false so this one is not required
then we are just returning for the sake
of the example but this is how we can
extract some something from the query
parameter and if we go to the
documentation
this is how we will use it uh we go to
the url
slash article we will send a post
request
to this url with the contents that we
are sending
we will pass the query parameter here
after after the the
the question mark and this will be big
model it was true to make it true
because by default it's false
and the documentation user interface
shows us these four parameters that we
declare and because we declared that it
was a boolean
a value then it automatically shows uh
the possible options that we have for
this query parameter
also a if we use this in the code
this big model even though we are
sending it in a query parameter
so let's go again back again to the url
we are sending this big model equals
true but this url
is all just like a big string and like
the
the server is receiving a string
like there's no a there's no like
standard
for other values in queries uh or in
urls in general
a apart from just like a long string
with several parts
but because we declared that this should
be a boolean fast api will take care of
converting
this big model to a boolean so we won't
receive like a string
containing the string false or something
we will receive a boolean
right like we declare it here
a okay we don't have to put everything
in the body
we can put parameters like in the query
whenever it's like
something that makes sense uh so we can
we have like
those options uh we actually have like a
lot more options but
let's uh keep it like that for now now
let's say that we want a facility
application
with the machine learning model that we
were using before so this is just
the same code we are just mixing it all
together we are creating a machine
learning model
this is a spacing model in this case we
are creating the fast api application we
are creating the body
that we want to receive with this class
a that we take from
a we create a inheritance from the base
model from pedantic
then we create this decorator app.post
so this is a post request go to
slash article slash and this is the
function that is going to handle this
it's going to receive an article which
is of an instance of this class article
so this is going to be taken from the
json
body and we have this big model which is
a boolean that by default is false this
big model we're just not going to use it
now because
it doesn't fit on the screen but we get
the idea of how to get data from the
query parameter
now here we are using the model that we
loaded before
this model is from here and we are using
it here
to read the content of the article so we
declare that this article has a
text content uh this is string content
from here we are just passing it through
the machine learning model we're getting
the
document object and we are interacting
for each one of the entities
and the entities detected in this
document object
uh what we are doing here is not that
magical we are just like adding the
entities to a big list
so for each one of the entities we are
adding text
of the entity and the label of the
entity and we are just returning it
the message contains what is the the
content of the article and the entities
contain the entities
that we detected big mole just is
sending like the same big
parameter that we received so this is
quite simple and quite straightforward
and if we interact with that and we send
the data
with a our documentation user interface
we will receive
the data that we are requiring we can
interact with it live
and check it like in the browser
directly if everything is working
correctly
now let's say that we have a very
complex shape
in the data that we want to receive now
we don't want to receive a single
article
we want to receive a json array that
contains objects
in the json boy so we want to receive
several of these
articles and each one of these articles
inside of it has a comments which is a
list of strings or like a json array of
strings like the term in json is array
but in python is list
and in json is objects but in python is
dictionaries
but it refers to let's say kind of the
same thing
now we are declaring just the same data
and
now we are importing from typing we
import list this
typing is part of standard python
and this list is part of standard python
this list a is the way that we used to
declare that something is of type
of list and we inside of it we pass what
is the internal type so this is the same
thing that we were doing here before
uh this is just a standard fight we are
not doing anything
strange we don't have to learn like a
new syntax or a new set of classes or
anything this is
uh standard python type annotations now
we are declaring that
articles should be a list that contains
a in each one of the items should be one
of this article
an instance of this class article that
we declare so there will be something
with this shape
now we are doing more or less the same
we are doing a an
empty entities and a response for each
one of the articles in
articles for article in articles we are
ready for each one of the comments
inside of the comments for this article
and we are processing the comment
and then we are extracting the entities
for each one of those comments and then
we are just
adding that to the final response and
then we just return that response
so if if you check out that like just
saying
it just like saying it in plain english
it's kind of complex
and still we can fit all that code in a
single
slide so this is a fully
functional machine learning api
because like we can just use this very
simple
standard python features
and if we check it in the documentation
we can see that the example value is
updated we now have a list
we can see the square brackets here is a
list that should contain
this shape uh so documentation is
uh automatically updated and the data
will be automatically
serialized or converted like a fast api
will take care of converting all the
data that you send to this
type of data that we are receiving so if
you look for something is a boolean or
an integer
it will read it and convert it to an
integer
to really like the the in the shape that
you declare
now what happens if we send invalid data
after now we have seen that fast api
uses this is standard type annotations
so like by default because you are using
standard python type annotations
independent of fast api or anything by
default you will get
a automatic autocompletion in your
editor and you will get type checks we
are going to see a little bit more
about that in a second and fast api is
using
those standard type annotations to
generate documentation for you
and this documentation is actually
provided by swagger ui
which is a third-party user interface
library which uses open api which is the
standard that we
talked about so this is just like all
based on standards
and fast api is also providing you
serialization of the data that comes in
but not only that uh let's see what
happens if we send invalid data
so in this case we are sending a list so
this is correct
this list contains objects so yeah this
is
fine this is a json object this is also
json object all these are json objects
so that's fine
we send one that has a content it has
some string apple buys uk startup for 1
billion
and it has some comments nice it was
expected
these are strings so this is all valid
data now we have another object which
has a content which is microsoft creates
new a project template with fast api and
space
this one has a content which is a string
this is all valid but this one doesn't
have comments
but if we check back at the code that we
declared
the comments is a list of strings that
by default is an empty list so this is
not required we are accepting it's
data that doesn't have this because uh
we say that by default it's an empty
if we remove this part it will be
required but we are not requiring it
because
no it doesn't have to have comments all
the time so this is also valid
but then we send another another one
that says
text invalid data won't be accepted
and if you check closely this one is
sending a text
this is not a content and we declared
that we were going to receive a content
not a text so this one is not valid
and this one it has a content that says
this content is fine but
comments and then if we check the
comments the first one is a string so up
to here
everything is valid but then this one is
a strange json object which has this
strange
message key which has a value of oh no
adjacent object
so this thing here which is deeply
uh like buried inside of the data that
we are sending is actually not valid
with
the shape that we declare and if you see
this is inside of a list
inside of a json object inside of
another list
and checked as a as a string
if we try to send that we will receive a
an invalid data error that is sent
automatically by fast api we don't have
to do anything to get
this automatically and we are not just
getting an error we are getting an error
that tells us
exactly where the problem is so we can
see that the error is in the body
and it's in the index 2
so here we have a list of errors this is
the first one
and this is in the index 2 if we go back
this is index 0
index 1 in this 2. so in index 2 we have
an error
now what is the error the error is in
content
and if we see here we have text instead
of content and what is the error that
the field was required the content field
is required we didn't send the content
field
now we can see the order the other error
which is a in index
three so this is index 0 index 1 index 2
index 3 and then index 3
in the inside of the comments index 3
inside of the comments in index
1 so this is index 0 and this is index
one
what is the error the error is that the
string type
expected so this it was expecting a
string type
so we can get data that tells us that
the error in all this thing was
exactly here and here
and we don't have to do anything for
fast api to do it
for us because we are declaring the data
with let's go back
up here where this is standard
uh well like pydantic is like a
very nice library that uses this
standard type annotations but we are
using pythag internally so we can just
use
standard python notations and fast api
can do all the data validation for us
so for this code that you write
for this code to execute uh you just
have to declare
for this code to execute the data has to
be valid so
this code won't be executed if the data
is not already valid fast api will take
care
of giving you only valid data this is
saving us i don't know
10 50 lines of code or something because
we can just like uh take care of the
business logic
of our application instead of like
having to do all the manual
handling of validating all these data
so if we send this invalid data
we get an error so with invalid data
fast api
won't receive it and that the code
inside of our application won't even be
run uh if we send invalid data
so we don't have to take care of that
after declaring
the data shapes now
we have been talking about auto
completion how is this auto completion
thing like what is the idea with that
here we are declaring a parameter
articles which is
a list of this thing article and we are
going to completion
inside of our code even for deeply
nested
data structures so we are iterating for
each one of the articles
we are looking for this article in all
the articles and then we rewrite them
for each one of the comments inside of
that article which is
coming from the list so this comment if
you see
is inside of a a nested for loop
and we are going to completion in this
nested data structure this is very
difficult to achieve
with all their uh with all their
ways to declare these data shapes uh if
they are not using like standard
a python type annotations but because
fast api
uses these standard python python type
annotations we can just like get
auto completion for free in the code
everywhere
also notice that this comment was not
something declared by fast api
this is your own data so you declared
your own data here and you are getting
out of completion for your own data
in in your code and type checks
uh if we go back this comment comes from
here
this comment will declare that is part
of this article.comments
and this is all strings so this comment
should be a string
if we try to perform an operation like
this string plus
some integer we will get uh uh an
automatic error in the editor telling us
that hey you cannot sum a string with an
integer so we can see like a lot of the
errors that we could be
writing in our code even before running
the application
and this is all based on standard python
type annotations
okay now let's talk about the uh
metadata let's say that we have all our
application it's everything everything
is fine it's cool but we want to add
more documentation
so we have this big model thing which is
a boolean
now we want to add this description here
so we can from fast api import this
extra thing this query and now instead
of having the false
that we have here with the default value
we are using this query here
and we are adding the description inside
of this query
for this big model which just says use
the big model
and if we go to documentation we can see
that the documentation now
has this description that we added use
but now the place that we use for the
default value we are using it to add
this extra
metadata so this query thing
receives as the first parameter what
will be that default value so we can
still keep the default value that we
were using
that we had before this false we just
pass it as the first parameter to query
and now query a has is not our value
because it has a default
which is by default false and we have
the additional
metadata we can also like have a
a dog string for just like the the the
string that goes that is like the first
a part inside of the function and it
will be used as the documentation for
this
api endpoint
and there's like a several places that
you can just add documentation for
your data inside of your code so that
the documentation is
tightly uh like close
to the thing that it is describing
so you don't have to write documentation
outside
of the code that is actually running the
thing you don't have to
keep updating a wiki somewhere else
so that the front 10 team doesn't come
complaining that it's not working again
because you're just updating something
because
everything will be kept in sync because
you just write the documentation
right in your code now let's say that we
want to add a required query parameter
so this is going to be let's say that we
want to add a language and this is going
to be a string
and because this is a simple value this
will also be taken from the query
parameter
the same way that we do in python
functions
because we didn't declare any default
value here
we are just declaring the type as a
string then fast api will interpret this
as
a required parameter if we check the
documentation we can see
that lang is now a require parameter if
we try to execute it
to execute this request as it is
uh like even the user interface won't
let us before adding the required query
parameter
and if you use like call or some
or code to call this directly you will
get a validation error if you send
something
without the required query parameter so
when you send data without the required
parameters
your api won't let it just pass through
now let's say that we sent
some valid data so this is actually
valid we this is how
we will send it in the in the url
after the question mark we pass lang and
this is going to be equals to
n sorry if we send that then we will get
the result
as we expect
this is something to have in mind one
does not seem to make all query
parameters required
have in mind that it's not common for
apis to have required query parameters
so if you need to have a required query
parameter
documented well and well you just it
will be documented automatically but
just have in mind to not add a lot of
them because it's probably not going to
be expected by the clients of your api
but still you can do it if you need it
now let's add some extra validation the
afternoon of cpi is taking care of
making sure that if it's required
we provide that it has the shape and the
value that we declare
but we can have additional validation
now we are going to
say that this length parameter should
have a minimum length
of two and a maximum length of two so we
are going to use
a code for the language uh for english
it will be
en er and
we have this this validation here and
then facebook will take care of uh
performing that validation is actually
all done through pedantic
but because we no longer have we are now
using this
uh default value that we
didn't have anything here uh so this
could
mean that it will be a in a python
function this will mean that this will
be
uh not required a
parameter so to fix that we can pass
these three dots here this means
that this a that this parameter is
required
and these three dots is called ellipsis
this is a python simple
this is valid python syntax and this is
the way we also use
input antique to declare that something
is required when we need to add extra
validation
or extra metadata or anything like that
and we're also using the same query
thing that we were using here before
just that in for the big mold the fault
value is false
and for length the default value is
these three dots
which is the symbol called ellipsis
which means that
this line is required and we we check in
the documentation and we try to send
something that is not valid so this has
a three letters instead of two then we
get an error as we would expect
but if we send valid data then again it
works as we expected
so without valid data the
application or api fast api will contain
with validate i will just go
happily and run your code
so now a about performance fast api is
actually built on top
of a starlet and starlet is a framework
which is like what what gives all the of
the performance
for fast api a fast api is in the top
rank
uh like the performance available for
python frameworks this is an independent
benchmark the blue things are python the
green things are
called a gold line which is a compiled
language so
this is not a fair comparison but you
can see that
fast api at least for some situations
can be even faster that some
golden frameworks
which one of these is the fastest is not
that
necessary that's relevant they all get
kind of the same ballpark
uh like even more here's unicorn which
is
apparently under fast api on ubicorn is
the server itself so this is not even a
framework this is the thing that
runs starlet that runs fast api if a cpa
runs on top of starlet so this one
should be on top of everyone else
but the thing is that you get like on
the ballpark of the best performance
available that you can
that you can get and you get
like data validation data socialization
documentation and everything for free
and if you check here we are having more
than 15 000 requests per second
so this is actually over 9 000 requests
so this is quite good
uh cool there are some other features
there's
a dependency ejection system that you
can use to do authentication
or to do a to do
a like extra data that you need to reuse
in several places for example to extract
what is the current user
or to do some authorization systems you
can also
integrate security tools for oauth 2
authentication which is also integrated
with the a with the with the
user interface for the documentation
you can have web sockets these web
sockets is possible because fast api is
an asynchronous framework
which is based on starlit which is based
on the new standard ascii
well those are technical digital the
thing is that you can do web circuits
that you wouldn't be able to do
with most of the other
like established frameworks you can use
files
send files and it has integrated
background tasks
these tasks will be for things like
sending
an email notification or something short
and small that can
run on the same process these wouldn't
be to train models
if you need to train modes you will use
a celery
or rq or arq or some like bargain task
distributed system but for simple things
you can have background tasks that run
after sending the request there's easy
graphql integration if you need that and
there's a bunch of
other things that you can do there are
other tools a
typer is kind of the fastest the first
api of cls
this is to be built command line
interfaces it's also
based on type annotations it's like it
should feel more
less the same as using fast api and then
you get a well autocompletion inside of
your own data validation all that stuff
but the cli applications that you build
are going to have
shell completion for your users so
whenever they
use your command application and hit tab
they will have a completion for
subcommands
uh parameters for everything and this
will work for
bash uh seashell fish even
power shell in windows which is
something that
no one else provides as far as i know uh
like for modern powershell and for
recent versions
like for windows 10 and so think
is a the functional deep learning
framework
based on python type annotations which
is also compatible
with your favorite leverage so you can
integrate it with pytorch tensorflow
whatever you need
and it even has a plugin for doing
a like analysis of the types and the
type
shapes of your known pay arrays so it
can check that you have like
at least a a raise of the same rank if
you have like a three-dimensional array
and you can perform an operation with it
a you need to perf if you need to
perform an operation that
only works on the same shapes it's going
to detect them and things like that
when you do like deep learning uh
deep learning and models and that's all
i have for you
thank you very much if you want to check
the documentation it's in
fastapi.com.com
if you have questions i think we can
we can answer them now thank you thank
you so much
that was a it was very very interesting
talk
rapid overview of basically everything
there is right
yeah more or less yeah yeah so we have
been running
uh a bit over time so i think what we'll
do is we'll answer one question live
i think there's um there's a really good
one and then we'll take the rest of them
to discord so we can answer them offline
and people can
sorry for the delays no no no worries at
all if people need to leave they can
always leave quite easily nowadays um so
i think
the biggest question um sort of the two
questions that were asked
what if you have like a big api with
several routes in different files
but they need to use the same model like
how would that work how would you
structure it
how would you pass the model to the
wraps yeah so there there's a whole
section in the facility documentation
about integrating bigger applications
uh with a way that you can separate your
like all your code and the sections of
your api and different like api
endpoints into sub routers
into api routers and you can integrate
all that in the same application so you
could load
your machine learning model in the let's
say one python
one python file and then import that
python file
from all your other audio python files
that handle each of the specific
sections
of your api okay that makes sense would
you use the dependency injection
functionality for something like this as
well or you will probably
yeah you will probably be able to use it
uh
the dependency injection system is very
useful when you need to have
something that for example needs to be
independent for each request
like a database session or when you need
to extract data from the request for
example when you need to get the
the current user and you uh to get the
current user you need to check it on the
database and to check it on the database
you extract the id
from a token that comes in a header
something like that
then you can use the dependency
injection to get like
that and reuse that everywhere because
that's data that will depend on
that on each specific request and the
dependency injection system will
get integrated into all the open api
documentation and everything so you get
like
documentation for the things that
require all the data to get
a user or things like that
okay that makes a lot of sense so maybe
a bit overkill for loading a model
just yeah yeah maybe it might makes make
sense in some cases like
if you for example need to load a
specific model for a specific
language or if you yeah like something
like that
but in other cases it might make more
sense to just like load it directly
but uh certainly you can use it like in
the scenarios that
that like work best
okay okay thank you so much so we'll
take the rest of the questions because
there's some good ones
let's take them to the discord um
talking about the discord we have
uh for each talk that we had tonight we
have a separate channel in which you can
ask questions or communicate with the
speakers but also we have
a channel called discussion and q a
which is a voice channel which might
also be fun to to hang around with and
and ask these kinds of questions